lo primero que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es contarte qué dice el teorema de
la bisectriz y después vamos a ver cómo
se demuestra bueno aquí tenemos un
triángulo abs y lo que voy a hacer es
trazar la bisectriz desde v en realidad
todo esto va a funcionar para la
bisectriz desde cualquiera de los
vértices vale pero ahorita lo vamos a
trazar desde b para que sea más cómodo
el dibujo bueno como es bisectriz este
ángulo es igual a este aquí a este punto
lo vamos a llamar el punto de a donde
llega la bisectriz y el teorema de la
bisectriz lo que dice es lo siguiente lo
voy a apuntar aquí arriba que ahora emma
de la bisectriz la bisectriz dice 3 lo
que dice es lo siguiente observa que
esta bisectriz ve de parte al triángulo
en dos pequeños triángulos
bueno pues las razones de los lados de
esos triángulos que no son la bisectriz
son iguales para ambos triángulos es
decir vea entre ade es lo mismo que
vence entre sede deja de escribirlo de
esta forma lo voy a escribir como ave
entre ade
ave entre ave ave es igual acb en 13 d
es igual acb se ve en 13 d muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos unas razones es
más déjame pintarlo con colores para que
será un poco más padre tenemos a ave
esta longitud de acá que va a ser color
blanco entre a de que voy a pintar en
morado entre a de esta de acá es igual
acb que voy a poner en color verde igual
acb se ve es esta de acá entre en 13 de
que voy a pintar de color amarillo bueno
ahí está más o menos en color amarillo
pero la voy a pintar más amarillo vale
en 13 d bueno entonces este teorema está
bien padre nos da una relación entre
ciertos segmentos a través de una
igualdad de razones pero bueno o sea por
muy padre que esté no podemos darla por
hecho así nada más porque sí sería bueno
ver de dónde sale o cómo la podemos
mostrar y justo eso es lo que voy a
hacer en el resto del vídeo
bueno como tenemos una igualdad de
razones a lo mejor sería buena idea
encontrar triángulos semejantes y aquí
pues tenemos los triángulos abed y cbd
pero aunque compartan este ángulo el
ángulo aquí arribita en realidad no
sabemos mucho más acerca de esos
triángulos entonces como no sabemos casi
nada no podemos concluir que son cosas
que son semejantes y entonces la idea es
construir otro triángulo que nos ayude a
probar esta igualdad y una forma de
hacer eso es prolongar esta bisectriz
prolongar la bisectriz ya que la
bisectriz bd déjame prolongar la más o
menos como por acá vale entonces esta es
la continuación de la bisectriz y trazar
una paralela a ave que pase por ce a lo
mejor esta demostración te puede parecer
un poco extraña y no entiendas muy bien
de dónde salen las ideas pero no te
preocupes a mí también me pareció
extraña la primera vez que las vamos a
ver más o menos cuál es el plan entonces
vamos a trazar la paralela a ave que
pasa por si más o menos algo de este
estilo déjame ponerle color blanco para
que la paralela se entienda quería de
veras es paralela este d
acá entonces esta es paralela a esta de
acá vale lo voy a apuntar a ave es
paralela hace digamos cf a este punto le
voy a llamar
efe
y entonces el chiste es que al hacer
esto este ángulo empieza a brincar vale
este ángulo es un ángulo de una
transversal a estas dos paralelas y
entonces por ángulos alternos internos
este ángulo lo podemos pasar para acá
vale bf es una transversal de las dos
paralelas y este ángulo se pasa para acá
pero observa este ángulo de aquí abajo
es igual al de aquí arriba pero el ave d
es igual al de bs porque justo verde es
la bisectriz entonces este ángulo es
igual a este y este es igual a este
entonces bfc es congruente a c b
efe estos dos ángulos son iguales por lo
tanto en el triángulo bfc tenemos dos
ángulos de esta base iguales y así el
triángulo b
efe fcc es un triángulo isósceles con bc
con b c igual a c efe entonces al haber
trazado está paralela podemos concluir
podemos concluir que b c b c es igual a
c
y esto está bien interesante porque
bueno aquí en el teorema de la bisectriz
queríamos involucrar e involucrar e
involucrar a cb oa veces de alguna forma
pero si nada más teníamos dos triángulos
semejantes digamos este y este entonces
veces estaba muy abandonado pero bueno
gracias a que encontramos esta igualdad
de segmentos ahora este veces lo podemos
cambiar por un cf por un c f vale y
entonces bastaría demostrar esta
igualdad ave entre a de igual a cf / c d
pero bueno no no no quiero empezar con
el teorema más bien quiero llegar al
teorema entonces sigamos con lo que
estábamos haciendo tenemos que ver se es
igual a cf este triángulos isósceles y
lo que hicimos o bueno todo el plan era
intentar mostrar que había un triángulo
semejante al abed y un buen candidato es
el cfd porque ya tienen estos dos
ángulos en común entonces este
triangulito de acá y este triangulito de
acá parece que son semejantes y bueno ya
nada más bastaría encontrar un ángulo
más para que de adeveras fueran
semejantes pero eso está bien fácil
porque tienen
ángulo este ángulo en d opuesto por el
vértice entonces este ángulo de acá es
igual este ángulo de acá los dos
triángulos comparten dos ángulos y
entonces bueno con eso comparten tres
ángulos y por lo tanto son semejantes
entonces déjame ponerle aquí que el
triángulo a bb a bbb es un triángulo
semejante al y aquí es importante ir de
nada azul rojo al c nada azul
efe c efe rojo de entonces el triángulo
abed es semejante al triángulo cf d por
el criterio ángulo ángulo y con esto
podemos aprovechar las razones entre los
lados y a lo mejor con eso ya
demostramos el teorema de la bisectriz
bueno vamos a ver que tenemos aquí
queremos ave entre a de que sería este
lado entre este lado si tenemos
triángulos semejantes podemos comparar
razones de lados correspondientes o bien
tomar dos lados encontrar su razón y esa
razón es igual a la razón de los lados
correspondientes entonces vamos a ver
cuánto es a b / a
a semejanza voy a agarrar el color
naranja entonces ave ave entre a de
entonces sería ave con a de vámonos aquí
a la semejanza para ver cuál es la razón
correspondiente sería cf cf entre en 3cd
en 13 d en 13 de ahí esto ya está súper
padre porque justo acabamos de probar
que cf es igual a veces entonces esto de
aquí es igual abc o bien podemos
escribirlo como se ve se ve en 13 de
entonces ave entre a de ave entrega d es
igual acb en 13 de eso es justo lo que
queríamos demostrar va entonces todo
salió muy bien y fue gracias a trazar
esta paralela de aquí entonces para para
demostrar el teorema de la bisectriz
tuvimos que hacer dos cosas número uno
trazar esta paralela y ver donde
interpretaba a la prolongación de la
bisectriz y número dos a partir de eso
demostrar alguna
y de ahí salieron dos cosas bien
importantes para empezar este ángulo por
ser alterno interno con este se pasó
para acá y nos permitió demostrar un
isósceles de modo que veces era igual a
cf y entonces pudimos meter a veces en
la jugada pero más aún esa misma
paralela nos permitió encontrar la
semejanza de los triángulos adb y cdf
entonces combinando esta semejanza con
la igualdad de estos dos segmentos la el
teorema de la bisectriz simplemente se
convirtió en una consecuencia de la
igualdad de ciertas razones